- Bonjour! Remerciement
voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
- À Marseille, le temps est
pluvieux et maussade. Un ciel
à l'image de l'humeur des
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélencho
radicale.
- C'est pénible et
c'est fatigant.
- Leur candidat a été éliminé au
premier tour, jujujujujustesse.
- 108 000 sur tout Marseille.rt,
"La France insoumise",
s'impose à gauch
- C'est pour ça
- Ces militants tiennent donc
à remercierctctctctctcteurs,
qui sont nombreux à Marseille.
C'est après tout dans le centre
de la vill d d d d d d d d d d é
Jean-Luc Mélenchon. Que Leront
ces él d d d d d deuxième tour
de la présidentielle?
Voilà la grande question.
- Je n'irai pas voter, Monsieur,
parce qu'entre la peste
et le choléra, je préfère
rester chez moi.
- Franchement, on va aller
voter parce qu'on veut pas
que Marine Le Pen, elle passe.
On va aller voter pour Macron,
mais c'est vraimenttrtrtrtrtrtr.
- Vote stratégique ou
abstention, ces électeurs
de gauche détermineront
en partie du sort de l'é
militante, La France insoumise
- Bon, bien sûr, on a ét
aux résultats du premier tour.
Mais ceci dit, comme on a fait
un bon score, on voit
nos adversaires
sont tous rivés.... ont tous
les yeux rivés sur nous parce
qu'ils se dema
- D'où les mains tendu
venu récemment à Marseille, où
il a promis un deuxi
plus vert.
EMMANUEL MACRON, candidat,
La République en m,,,,,,,,,,,,,,
le 10 avril dernier dans
les urnes, un
pour mettre l'environnement
au coeur de notre campagne
et des année
(acclamations de la foule)
du président espèrent que cette
nouvelle approche leur permettra
de faire des gains.
ESTELLE FAURE
Les jeunes avec Macron
aux Français qu'il les écoute.
Et ça, pour nous, c'est très
important parce qu'on nous a
longtemps critiqués, qu'on
n'écoutait pas les Françai
à une demande des Français.
- Bonjour, pour Emmanuel Macron.
- Surtout pas!
- Une conseueueueueueueueueueues
de La France insoumise
a montssssssss
d'entre eux sont prêts
à voter pour Emmanuel Macron,
maispupupupupupupupupupupupupupr
l'un ou l'autre des candidats
ouououououououour de l'élection
présidentielle.
Un vote pour Marine Le Pen
le cadre de cette consultation.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à ses partisans de ne pas
appuyer l'extrême droite.
- (foule): On va gagner,a a a a!
- Et pourtant,
qui veut fédérer le vote
anti-Macro
en partie sur les appuis
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
MARINE L
- Ce rendez-vous du 24 avril,
vous adadadadadadadadadames
et Messieurs, met face à face
le bloc populaire contre
le                             é
sociale contre le bloc de ceux
attachés au pouvoir de l'argent.
- Merci.
- S'ils abordent des thèmes
chers nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn,
les militants du Rassemblement
naucucucucucucucucucucoup
l'accent sur des enjeux
économiques et sociaux comme les
Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Z,Ze
pour le Rassemblement national ,
c'est de baisser les prix.
On n'arrive plus. Il y a'e'e'e'.
La première urgence,stststststsé
socialement la France, je pense
vraiment, Emmanuel Macron.
de la droite. Ils ont été déçus:
"Pourquoi, après tout,
ne pas essayer Marine?"papapapa,
mais je comprends qu'il y aààààé
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
au premier tour. Dimanche,
son vote.
- Bien triste,
pays, on est en train
de le démolir.??????????????????
- L'élection prési
de dimanche, peu importe son
résultat, ne mettra visiblement
pas fin au désen
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Marseille